good afternoon everyone uh thanks for
coming my name is Anna Tavares I'm an
associate research scientist at Columbia
University and I'm a co-founder and
president of basis Research Institute
and today I'm going to talk about
reasoning in various different forms
so this is the James Webb Telescope it
has 18 mirrors 132 actuators and it's
allowed us to see far into the galaxies
so I'm sure many of you have seen over
the last few months images produced uh
you know just wonderful pictures
but what interests me as a scientist is
more about the minds of scientists how
is it that we can construct these
somewhat magical devices and one of the
ideas that I follow is that there are
some principles of intelligence that are
kind of conveyed in scientists but also
conveyed in children
um that there are some kind of key ideas
which allows my my friend's son to build
this Lego piece that also allows us as
scientists to understand how the world
works and so a lot of my work is trying
to understand these principles and
automate them in artificial intelligence
in particular one of the things I focus
on is reasoning and so today I'm going
to talk about reasoning from three
different perspectives
um knowledge representations because the
reason and Reliance in knowledge
algorithm to reason in and new kinds of
reasoning it's going to be a pretty high
level talk but feel free to you know
come and talk to me for any more details
uh after the after the talk
so I'm going to start with uh knowledge
representation and advances knowledge
representation and I'll just show you a
short video
okay so there's many questions we can
now ask
um you know how fast is how fast is this
car going is this you know is this
incoming car going to hit the the purple
car and one of the ideas that I work
with is that the way that we as humans
can answer these questions is by having
a model of the outside world within our
within our own minds so
so the basic idea is this as a human uh
you have some kind of model of the
outside world in your mind and you can
use that model to make predictions about
the future and that's useful because you
can imagine how the future will involve
will evolve without the future actually
evolving
we can also use this to plan so if we're
playing Jenga for example we can imagine
what pieces to take before actually
taking those pieces
and these models that we have in our
minds they don't have to be about just
physics they can also be about other
people so I can think about what you're
thinking about I can think about what
you're thinking about what I'm thinking
about humans have this remarkable
capacity to model the outside world and
to use that model to make inferences
about the future
and so this is not a new idea
um actually if you go back you know
several decades one of the earliest kind
of experiments and experiments into this
what's what's called like mental
rotation and so the experiment is set so
people showed uh participants images so
pairs of images and the question I asked
was are these images taken from the same
object rotated or are they actually
different geometric structures and so I
do this exercise with you so I'll go
through ABC so raise your hand if you
think that a is the same image same
object rotated or it's actually a
different object
okay what about B
what about C
okay I actually forget forget oh uh
forget the answer right um what they
what they found is that if you plot the
angle of rotation right so the magnitude
of the angle of the rotation of the of
the object
and you plot the amount of time that it
takes people to respond this is very
tight linear correlation right and so
what that means is that in other words
like the bigger the angle right uh the
longer it takes for people to respond
and so the implication there is that the
way people respond to this question is
that they are basically mentally
rotating the object in in their mind and
so I'm sure probably you thought that
you were doing that and so it has some
kind of scientific evidence that you are
actually doing that
and so you know in the in the kind of
the the intermedia years we've been
formalizing this idea in mathematics and
computation and one of the key ideas is
the idea of a generative model
and so if you've you know if you've
heard of Dali or gpd3 these are
generative models uh in the sense that
they can generate data but this idea is
quite old and so there's many different
kinds of Genesis models that we can have
what's called a probabilistic uh
uh context-free grammar we can have a
graphical model we can have something
like Dali all of these things they
generate data often in some
probabilistic way
and the thing that I focused on in our
research focuses on is simulation models
and the basic idea is as we just
described there is the real world on the
left hand side we can build some kind of
simulation model of that in the middle
and we can use that simulation written
in code to make inferences about the
future
okay so that's all kind of very very
familiar
um but one kind of twist is this idea of
a problem it's probabilistic simulation
so on the left hand side we have the
normal code right so this is a kind of a
toy stimulation of of you know some kind
of driving scenario where we have some
velocity some height some weight and so
on and we can imagine doing some kind of
time step simulation into the future
and the first thing that a probabilistic
simulation does is it replaces some of
the constants in that simulation with
random variables so distributions which
reflect our uncertainty about the True
Value so here I'm replacing uh the speed
of the card the velocity V1 with some
distribution of a V1 so maybe a 60 miles
an hour maybe it's 50 59 miles an hour
and it reflects our uncertainty over the
True Value
so perhaps it's also very familiar maybe
maybe some of you have already done kind
of probabilistic simulations
the key idea is this idea of inference
and so what I'm showing you here in the
bottom is yeah you have kind of these
two things one I can add data so I've
got my observations so I've observed the
the frames of video that we saw but in
particular I want to compute inferences
I want to be able to do reasoning and so
I want to be able to say how fast should
I believe that the car is going given
that given the images that I've seen
or do I think the car is going to crash
given up given what I've seen
so
how does how should we do this so the
mathematics that described how to do
this is called Bayesian inference and
it's described by some laws which I'm
showing you here
um I'm not going to get into the details
of what they are but at a high level
they allow us to take a model to take
some data and combine those to get a new
belief about on certain variables in our
model
and so one of the areas that we work on
are programming languages called
probabilistic programming languages to
automate this this process of resonance
and so there's you know kind of a growth
of these over the last decade or so uh
here are some of the most popular ones
and they are essentially programming
languages with this feature of
conditioning with evidence
Nick so you write down the model you
write down the data and you say here are
some questions that I have and they
automatically compute the answer and so
a lot of what we've been we've been
building on is is using this as a
foundation so probabilistic programming
languages if you haven't played with
them here are some of the most popular
ones
um pyro is is part of uh part of our
team I didn't develop at my stock
personally but many people in my team do
a compiler but we're thinking about what
is next in the World of reasoning
algorithms and systems
okay so I want to go back a little bit
and to this idea of mental rotation so
if you think about what's going on as a
computer scientist you might think well
somehow I've got some kind of data
structure in my mind and I use and I
apply some operations to that data
structure and that's what allows me to
do this kind of mental rotation
and thinking about data structures uh
you know they're very commonplace in
programming I'm sure everybody's
everybody here has used sets and lists
and stacks and and arrays and so on and
just as as humans in everyday life we
use these kind of structures mentally so
if I line up to get food I'm doing some
kind of Q operation in my mind
um
but if you look at machine learning
there's nothing like these kind of
structures in modern machine learning
and so one of the questions that we've
been thinking about is how do we bridge
this gap between these this feature
which is a data structure which is
obviously very important to all of
computer science and machine learning
which seems to not have anything like
that
so taking a step back one way to think
about this is an idea called levels of
analysis and this might be quite kind of
familiar in some sense to computer
scientists and programmers but maybe the
particular terminology you haven't heard
of before and so so the basic idea is
from somebody called David ma who was a
scientist at MIT
and I heard this idea when I when I
joined MIT and the basic idea is that
you can understand an information
process and system at different levels
of analysis so at the highest level you
have What's called the computational
level and this is basically saying what
is the system trying to do it's more
like the spec at the second level you
have the you know what are the
algorithms that this system is using to
compute uh this computational goal
and then the third level is what is the
actual implementation and that could be
on you know the program and Hardware but
it could also be you know on our web in
terms of our brain
and the key idea behind these levels of
analysis is that there's a kind of a
many-to-one or one-to-many relationship
you can have many different algorithms
which compute the same computational
goal you can have many different
implementations which compute the same
algorithm
and so going back to this idea of a data
structure we can understand data
structures at a higher level than you
know the particular implementation and
so one of the things that we've been
working on is saying well you know what
what is the stack really so a stack at
the highest level is something which if
you push to that stack and then you pop
you get back the same stack you started
with and you get back the same object
that you pushed on in the first place
and so this is like the high level
algebraic law of a stack but can we take
that high level law and turn it into
something at the lower levels
implemented using modern machine
learning methods
so I'm going to kind of skip over how we
actually do it but the the high level
process is we take this kind of high
level law and translate that into a loss
function which we can train using
machine learning techniques
and so what does that mean in practice
so what I'm showing you here is uh kind
of this neural stack so to be concrete
we've trained this push function we've
trained the pop function both of which
in your networks and we train this kind
of constant empty vector and so the
first thing to see is that essentially
it works as a stack so I'm pushing on
eight six and four and I'm popping three
times and I'm getting back the same
thing that I I pushed on
the more interesting thing is the
intermediate level which is certain
shown like how does a neural network
represent a stack and so if you look at
let's say the fourth digit across that's
the internal representation of this
neural stack after having pushed eight
six and four and if you look clear if
you look carefully you can see it's
somehow learned to interlace these
different uh images so that it can then
further pull out the information at once
so again so this is a stack in in any
kind of real sense of a stack but it's
implemented in a very different way you
wouldn't know how to code this up
yourself but you can train it if you
just try to adhere to the high level
laws of what a stack is
and we can do the same thing for
essentially arbitrary data structures so
you take a queue or uh you know a tree
and if you can write down what it means
to be that data structure at the high
level we can compile that into a loss
function that we can train basically
arbitrary neural networks to do
so this is kind of you know uh still
early still early work right but we
think it's kind of the first you know
really interesting approach which we can
take to bridge this divide between data
structures and kind of modern machine
learning techniques
I think my screen is slightly zoomed in
there we go
um
well maybe that's not that I had any
okay
Okay so
the next thing I want to talk about is
advances in reason and uh algorithms so
this is uh Galileo or galilei's
experiment where he's dropping two
different objects to figure out uh if
they thought at the same speed or not
and one of the things more generally
that's interests me is this idea of
scientific discovery that I spoke about
at the start and in particular the
history of scientific discovery all the
way you know back to ancient times
and so there's been many different kind
of theories and classes of theories all
the way you know from uh to let me up to
Newton through to Modern string theory
and so on and one basic question is you
know what if you know if we have all
these different theories what is the
space in which these theories are
instances of like in other words like
what is the type of a theory
and one idea that I find quite
compelling is the idea that theory is a
little bit like programs uh in other
words like the space of theories is a
little bit like the space of programs
and therefore scientific discovery is a
little bit like program synthesis and so
this idea of like using program
synthesis where programs are models and
program synthesis is like Theory
Discovery uh is you know has seen some
kind of cool work in recent years and so
here are some examples uh by Kevin Ellis
uh by far Assad and some work that I'll
talk about right now
okay so this is uh system uh kind of a
video game system and I'll just show you
what it is on the right hand side so on
the left hand side we have essentially a
interface some some code and a language
that we created called Autumn and so
this is a kind of reactive programming
language and on the right hand side we
have an interface and I'll just show you
a very simple example
so I'm going to press play and this is
just compiling the code and running it
interactively in the browser
and I'm clicking as you can see and you
know essentially this these are blue
dots are appearing and moving around
and so I haven't seen this you probably
already automatically formed a theory
about how this world works like maybe
it's something like wins and Eclipse
some kind of dot appears and it moves
around randomly and that is true and
that is kind of what this code on the
left hand side does
and so the problem that we're trying to
explore explore here is how do we build
a system that like you can observe the
sequence of video frames and the actions
that I did and figure out the program on
the left hand side
so from video and user input to program
and so to kind of broaden my analogy we
think this is a little bit like science
because you're observing what's
happening in the world and you're trying
to figure out some kind of theory on the
line uh the behavior that you're seeing
and so in many ways this is a very hard
problem and I'll just show you one
example to just to kind of explain why
so
let's see five
okay so here's an example right so
probably immediately you have some idea
about what you want to try right so I'm
going to click and you can see uh some
some dots coming down
and so one of the really hard things is
that if I click this this kind of yellow
thing nothing happens uh at least
observationally the world the visual
world has not changed but something
internally in the program has changed
right so if I click again now a yellow
dot is coming down so this is hard for
AI algorithms because the algorithm has
to figure out that there's some latent
or hidden state that has chains in
response to what I've done but has made
no visual change in the world
uh and so you might think okay what's
going to happen now if I press uh blue
or you might think that it's going to
make a blue point but it does something
different
and so this process of like building
hypotheses about how the world works
also what experiments should I try to
you know invalidate or forsify my
experiment is what we've been exploring
In This Very simplified domain so
originally it's quite simple but it's
Rich enough to explore many of the
interesting components of science
Okay so
how do you actually how do you actually
do it
um that would be you know many talks in
of itself right but one way to think
about it is that an interpreter or a
compiler
uh takes his input a program and
produces his output the video frames
that I saw and what we kind of want to
do is the inverse of that process we
want something which will take the
videos that we saw and go backwards in
some sense invert the compiler or invert
The Interpreter to produce the program
that produced it
and you can check out this paper uh it's
on my website to see the details of how
we actually how we actually do it
but this idea of inversion right so we
can think about this as I just said uh
inverting The Interpreter is is kind of
program so this is the motor synthesis
and this idea of inversion kind of pops
up everywhere when you start thinking
about reasoning
so what do I mean by inversion well I
mean you start with some model some
function uh that computes takes some
input X and produces some output y
uh and more generally you know that
function is expressed as a program and
so I want to invite the program that
computes that function
and so aside from the example that I
just said there's many were areas and
places in which this idea of inversion
shows up
so one example is in uh Vision right so
the real world is three-dimensional
unlike the video game that I just showed
you but what we observe as humans are
basically two-dimensional image images
your eyes observe two-dimensional images
and somehow your brain figures out the
three-dimensional structure of the world
from these from these two dimensional
images as input
and if you know anything about Graphics
you know that we actually know as
scientists and Engineers we know how to
do the forward process we know how to to
to take a three-dimensional
representation and do something called
rendering and output a two-dimensional
image and that's what you see when you
go to the movies when you play video
games it's kind of a well-established
field
but how do we do the inverse how do we
actually invert that rendering process
and go from the image to the images to
the to the 3D structure similarly in
robotics we know how to write a forward
kinematic function and that takes the
angles of the the joints of a robot and
says where is the hand
but often we want the inverse I want my
hand to be in some Target location what
should the joints be what should a joint
angle be and so we're often in this
regime where we have a forward model but
what we want is the inverse model
so why is this hard there's many reasons
why this is hard to do the first reason
it's hard is most interesting things are
not invertible so in the case of
um kind of this 3D example I've got
these two scenarios on the left and on
the right and in the right scenario
we've got this additional uh green
sphere at the back but it makes no
difference to the image right because
it's occluded there's something in front
of it right that could you know in other
words like there could be many things
behind my back and they would all
produce the same perception for you
we don't have to go to something as
complex as rendering to see this if I
just tell you that you know two numbers
X and Y sum to five and I ask you what
are X and Y well it could be that X is
three and Y is 2 or X is 4 and Y is one
all of these are different possibilities
and so the addition function is the
non-invertible function
and so the idea that I had is this idea
started in in grad school and we've kind
of been continuing it since is to
generalize the notion of inversion with
something I call a parametric inverse
okay so what do I mean by parametric
inverse so let's take addition as a very
simple example so like we just you know
discovered addition is not invertible
but I can Define this parametric inverse
and so this parametric inverse F to the
minus one takes in some value Z and some
parameter Theta and returns two values Z
minus Theta and Theta the basic idea
being that Z minus Theta for X add Theta
is equal to Z right so if I put in Z as
some number like 5 and then I choose
Theta arbitrarily then I'll get out two
values one for x and one for y and as I
vary Theta I'll get back all the
different possible combinations of X and
Y all of which sum to uh Z
constructively
and you can do the same thing for the
square function right f of x and y sorry
f of x equals x squared again uh in the
inverse direction there's two Roots but
I can just parameterize that choice so I
get back the positive and negative root
this in this case uh where Theta
determines which of the roots I get
so that's you know hopefully that that
makes sense
um but by itself isn't that useful the
key idea is that we can apply this idea
through composition so if I have two
functions composed so I have F of X and
Y equals X Plus y squared I can think
about that as the composition of the
addition function and the square
function and so here's the algorithm in
a nutshell I'm going to take the
addition function I'm going to take the
square function I'm going to replace
addition with its parametric inverse
replace the square function with this
parametric inverse and invert the order
of the composition right and so during
that process my claim to you is that
results in a parametric inverse of the
original forward composite function
so okay so
why do we care well we care because
programs despite being millions of lines
long and very complicated ultimately
reduced down to a small number of
primitive operations
and so if we can uh through virtue of
composition Define uh the inverse of
composite functions we can actually
invert programs
so our goal in a nutshell is to be able
to produce a system where you write down
as a programmer your program on the left
hand side and that could be an arbitrary
program in whatever uh you know whatever
complexity you want
and then we just say invert and we have
some compiler process which will take
that forward program and spit out an
inverse of that program
and what our kind of theorem shows is
that actually we can do this by
construction now again this is still
still early days right and there are
many technical challenges one reason why
you should be skeptical is that if what
I'm saying is true I should be able to
just take your your hash function
inverted and still love you steal all
your Bitcoin right which we know is you
know not we know hash functions are not
things that are easy to invert so this
the story is more complex and again I
can talk about this in more detail
um but that's kind of the basic idea
which we're trying to follow
so taking a little bit of a step back a
broader view is that like many modes of
reasoning can be thought of as as
program transformations
um so this notion of inversion is can be
realized as a program transformation
another common one is automatic
differentiation so if you've done any
machine learning uh I can guarantee that
relies on automatic differentiation and
what is automatic differentiation well
it differentiates functions But
ultimately it's a program transformation
you write down some forward uh program
which defines a real real valued
function and these this ad method
constructs uh the derivative of that
function
so taking a narrow abroad of you
um program program compilation or
program transformation is a little bit
too broad many of the things that we
care about are really kind of what's
called a non-standard interpretation
and what that means is that you take
some program with its original syntax
and you give new meaning to that syntax
so in the in the case of
um parametric inversion it's saying well
my original program said add these
things and now I want to do the inverse
of that process
and so there's this kind of growing set
of tools uh which are allowing people to
give new meaning to their programs and
when we say meaning one of the ways that
we formalize this in programming
language research is through semantics
and so we have our program and our
compilers which I'm sure everybody here
is familiar with but there's something
called the semantics which defines the
mathematical description of what your
program actually is and that's normally
expressed in some kind of semantic rules
so this kind of funny looking lined
Expressions on the left hand side
what we want is some systems that can
allow us as programmers to go in and
change the semantics of our programs and
there's a growing kind of Small industry
of tools that are increasingly allowing
us to do that so Jax is one which you
may have heard of cassette is another
one based in Julia
um
an enzyme is the third one which
operates on a llvm level
and so this is still a very nascent area
and we're quite convinced that the
future of reasoning and inference will
rely on advancing this set of tools
tools that allow you to modify the
meaning of your program from within the
same programming language and that's
kind of some of the stuff that we're
working on now
okay so I'm gonna go back to my video
as I talk about different modes of
reasoning
and we can answer the question of you
know is this car going to crash or will
it crash
okay so it just just missed
um
so there's many many questions we can
ask so one kind of question which is not
within the kinds of questions that I've
spoken about so far so so far I'm
talking about inference prediction and
so on a different kind of question is
counter factual reasoning
so you might ask what you know would the
crash have happened had our car been 20
meters ahead right or had the incoming
carbon going 10 miles an hour faster
and so this kind of counterfactual
reasoning is everywhere you know
whenever you hear like a word or could
question this is kind of a
counterfactual question so here's an
example from you know a few years ago
where Mike Pence said if the swine flu
had been as lethal as the coronavirus in
2020 sorry in 2009 when Joe Biden was
vice president we would have lost uh 2
million American lives right so this is
a a counter factual statement right it's
a little bit morbid now because we have
lost almost 2 million lives right
um but so there's kind of a few
different things to think about and
counterfactual statements so one is that
they're kind of full spy construction
right it's based on the premise which is
not true but two there's a sense in
which you can evaluate whether it's a
value counterfactual or not and I'll
leave this to you to evaluate whether it
is or not
okay but what is it what is the
counterfactual kind of mathematically or
conceptually well as a kind of a toy
visualization so imagine we have this
model on the left hand side so this is
our normal kind of model of how the
world evolves so we've got time on the
x-axis and some kind of variable space
on the y-axis and so we've got these
different possible different possible
possibilities of how the world might
involve
in the middle we've got what we call
Bayesian inference before where we add
data to the system we add our knowledge
and that constrains the possible
possible Wells that could occur so we're
adding data
but a counter factual is on the right
hand side and that's saying well we've
got our data but we're also going to
construct this hypothetical and this is
saying well what if something were
different so it's almost like a cut to
the actual World in reality uh to
describe what you know what could have
happened or what would have happened had
something been different
yeah and so one of the areas that I work
on is sometimes called causal
probabilistic programming right where we
take the probabilistic programming
languages that we spoke about so so
sorry spoke about before Stan and Pyro
and so on and we add some constructs for
causality in particular for
counterfacturing reasoning and the basic
idea is that these languages allow you
to construct
in some sense uh twin Worlds the real
world which is your original program
which you've conditioned with evidence
in a way that probabilistic programming
systems allow you to do but two they
take that and allow you to construct
interventions and these interventions
essentially copy the entire world where
this new copied world has the kind of
the hypothetical that you're considering
at that time
and they manage all of the details about
how to do that for you so you just at a
high level you ask the question well
what would have happened had something
been different and it automatically
computes the answer for you
so the one the one I work on is called
Omega and I'll just show you some of the
examples that we can do
so imagine you're kind of driving a car
and then you see somebody uh pop out uh
some pedestrian pops out from behind an
obstacle and unfortunately uh you crash
into that uh pedestrian
and we can ask the question
um
you know the basic question is you know
to ask ask a question of like is the
fact that we were speeding uh the cause
of the crash happening or if you're a
police you know a police person you
might want to ask and answer this
question and so the goal in this
experiment was to take a single frame of
video uh in particular the image that
you're seeing right right here
and answer the question you know had the
car been going faster would the crash
have occurred
and to think about how we we actually do
that well we've got to take this image
we've got to go from the single image
back to the three-dimensional structure
of the world so we've got to invert this
rendering algorithm to construct the
three-dimensional uh structure we've got
to figure out how fast the car is going
based on some model of of car Dynamics
uh and figure out like when the driver
would have stopped given some model of
like when people generally stop when
they see a pedestrian
and given all the given all of that
knowledge then construct the
hypothetical you know would the crash
have occurred had something been
different
um and so it has a few different
scenarios right so there's the original
scenario where we crash on the left-hand
side
um there's a second scenario in the
middle had the obstacle been in a
different place and there's a third
scenario on the right hand side
um which is you know uh what if the
driver was going on to the speed limit
so here here are kind of the results and
so in this particular example this left
uh this left hand side image is saying
well had the driver been going slower
the distance ultimately between The
Pedestrian and the uh and the car would
still have been zero in other words the
car still would have crashed into The
Pedestrian most of the time right as you
can see here there's a distribution
right because all of these questions are
probabilistic in other words so go ahead
wait whale this people
that's slightly true right
um right and so the goal is that you
should be able to ask this question at
the level that you just asked it and the
system would automatically compute the
answer for you and so this is the
particular intervention that we're
asking uh it's not it's not like super
super fast right but it's a good point
on the right hand side we're seeing that
well had the obstacle been in a
different place
um well actually the crash probably
wouldn't have occurred right and so in
some sense you might blame the obstacle
for being where it was rather than the
driver but you know we can't generally
blame obstacles for things and so at a
high level that's the goal the high
level purpose is that you write down
your model you write down your question
and the system computes the answer for
you
another example where it was in a kind
of glucose modeling so here we have a
diabetic patient where we have different
attributes the glucose level in uh in
red how many steps they've taken whether
they've eaten and so on and so this
particular patient had a hypoglycemic
episode which means that the glucose
levels went too low
and so the question we want to ask is
would this have occurred had the patient
eaten a few hours before right and as
you can see from the the right hand side
image well actually it wouldn't have
occurred and so hasn't you know has the
kind of question a doctor might want to
be able to ask it all relies on the
knowledge which is added to the systems
for the simulation model and the goal of
the reasoning system is to be able to
automatically compute the questions to
hypothetical and counter factual
questions
okay so
um taking a step back there's kind of
three axes which I I've spoken about
right um
reason in algorithms uh most of the
reasoning and knowledge representations
and what we've been thinking about is
how do we advance along these these
three different axes
and if you look at kind of the history
of uh kind of computer science and AI
there's been a bunch of different
advancements along these and one of the
questions that we're asking and you know
asking is like what is what is the
future and how can we question these
three different dimensions
and so this idea of what one question is
okay so what is what is this limit like
if we keep pushing these three different
dimensions and that's what we're
informally calling this idea of
universal reasoning
um almost like a limit maybe an
unachievable limit of these uh
progressions
and this idea isn't new if you look back
to some of the earliest kind of pioneers
in computer science this is a leibniz on
the on the left hand side and intruding
in the middle and somebody could have
Simon on the right hand side all of
these people they had this idea of a
universal reasoning machine uh Universal
Universal calculator in different forms
and it's somewhat been lost to the kind
of advance of modern machine learning
and one of our goals is to somewhat
revive this ambition of a system that
can
perhaps match the ambition in which
these people thought of
okay so what do we mean by Universal
reasoning well we haven't got a precise
definition yet
um but it's something like something
like this well the first thing is that
it's necessarily going to be a proximate
and the reason it has to be approximate
is that uh you know humans and machines
are bounded by kind of space and time
you can only calculate so much within
our within our heads and the computer
can only calculate so much and so
approximation has to be part of the
picture where we're willing to sacrifice
Perfection uh in order to get some some
answers which may be good enough
and so what we mean by an approximate
approximately Universal reasoning
machine
is essentially a a complete
computational language so some language
which we can express our uh our
knowledge and and the problems that we
want to ask
uh which is Rich enough to express all
known computational problems
um and all known forms of knowledge
and paired that with reason and
algorithms is able to produce good
approximations uh sorry good approximate
Solutions within kind of the physical
constraints of time uh energy and maybe
even maybe even money
and so basis is in your organization and
our kind of reason to exist is to build
this kind of universal reasoning machine
and at a high level we we do two things
simultaneously one we build upon the
foundation that I've spoken about in
this talk so far of causality or
probabilistic inference of program
Discovery and we try and Advance along
these three different axes in
collaboration with the main experts
so we're a new kind of organization
um in the sense that we we build
collaborations with the main experts
both in hard scientific problems going
to what I said at the start and also in
societal problems uh in many different
areas
sorry about it's cut off right but um as
I just said the key one of the key
components is to work with collaborators
with with real problems right such that
those problems can drive kind of the
direction of the technology
and we're building this Foundation based
on based on reasoning and so just to
give an indication of the kinds of
problems that we work on one is
um what I just spoke about this idea of
automating scientific discovery Beyond
kind of the 2D simulation model that I
just showed you into like the real world
with with robots in other words can we
bought a robot that interacts with
physical devices in the real world not
with the goal of solving any particular
problem but with the sole goal of
figuring out how this particular device
works so a kind of intuitively intuitive
scientific discovery
more in the kind of the societal domain
we work with domain experts in New York
just to ask questions like well if we
instantiate this new policy what will
happen in New York what will happen to
homelessness what will happen to crime
and so this is interesting because if
it's hard enough to model one person
like how do you model an entire city of
interacting people in organizations and
so on and so we like projects which
really drive you know technology beyond
what we can do at the moment but also if
we can achieve them would have some kind
of good societal benefit
and third in purely kind of scientific
domains we work on like large-scale
biological problems like how do we
how do we Model A Cell how do we model
kind of genome uh transcription map you
know levels that haven't been done
before and so at high level this is
basis and we're a new organization very
much looking for for collaboration so if
you're interested in this kind of thing
uh feel free to reach out
and here are some of the kind of
esteemed collaborators as part of this
and I will end just finally on this last
video
thank you
[Applause]
um yeah good question so
I think part of the answer to that we do
have a good idea about uh in the sense
of
uh one of the ways in which people try
to quantify
um well one we can use probability to to
quantify our entirety but in particular
we can use Notions of Information Gain
right so I actually do experiments which
kind of maximize my information
information gained about the world and
that's something you can formalize quite
nicely you know using the relevant
mathematics what I think is hard to to
understand and is very much not so much
explored in academic literature is like
the idea that then
uh uncertainty is like relative to our
current knowledge so like if I just go
back to this example
well I showed you this purple Dot and I
showed you what happened with the yellow
Dot and you might think well what's
going to happen when I you know press
the red dot for example right but that
presupposes the idea that this red dot
is a button right which it might not be
so somehow you have to be able to
form hypotheses about questions relative
to your current knowledge while also
accepting the fact that your current
knowledge might itself just be wrong and
so that is kind of a hard a hard thing
that I think about a lot and I don't
quite have an answer to yet
right so I would probably distinguish
between complex and chaotic right so
there are some you know as you say
chaotic systems which are by Design
impossible to predict
um
but even then I think a key component is
abstraction right so I don't need you
know it'll be very hard to predict
you know where any person particular
person is going to be at any at any
particular time right let's say in 50
years time but I might be able to
predict you know the general population
trends of of different countries and so
some of some of the things which may be
kind of hard or in some cases actually
mathematically impossible to predict
might become tractable uh when you kind
of coarse grain a little bit and you ask
questions at a high level of abstraction
and in practice that's what everybody
does in science anyway right you always
you know you know I'm not trying to
predict where every atom is going to be
I'm always coarse granted to some degree
so I think you know in some sense it's
not not an answer like some of these
things are just also just hard at any
level of abstraction
um
uh but I think that's part of part of
part of the answer
yeah so there are um yeah so I think one
one thing I want to stress is that I
think in general like actual
universities the machine is probably
impossible right so we're always going
to be approximating
and humans have made certain
approximations both deliberately
deliberatively as the individuals but
some of these are just baked into our
biology right so we come into the world
with priors about how the world works I
mean I can take you know if I took your
visual system and scrambled the pixels
randomly it'll be the same information
but you wouldn't be able to navigate
anymore right so you're you're
your perception is is attuned to many
things which are just biological and so
I think humans are probably the most
General reason of machines that we have
some of the biases may be
um just kind of a quirk of our history
but there are just some fundamental
biases
and limitations that any agent will have
due to constraints on on computation and
you can understand actually many of the
constraints that humans do have in these
kind of rational like resource rational
terms like what should an optimal agent
do given that it has some constraints on
what it can do in finite time and finite
energy
yeah good question
um
the okay so the
one of the reasons I started basis as an
organization was
um
actually around the George Floyd protest
right so in that case remember that was
this conversation ongoing around
defunding the police right and so you've
got people on both sides some people are
saying oh it's crazy if you defund the
police everything's going to go to
Mayhem other people saying the police
have too much money and so on
one of the things I found dissatisfying
about that whole conversation is an
entanglement of two different things
right so one is a question of values
what kind of society do we want to live
in and the other is more like an
empirical question just what will happen
right
um if we Define the pleats in in some
particular way and so what I think is an
exciting potential for this kind of
thing is to somewhat disentangle these
two things right so that we can argue
about what values we want right but the
questions about what's going to happen
if we instantiate this policy
um it's not our opinion of it right
maybe it depends upon prior knowledge
which is somewhat subjective right but
it's a
um you know there's a matter of factness
about what what will actually happen
right and so I'm interested in can we
can we build can we bring to bear the
set of techniques which are quite
powerful but so far have have been kind
of used in somewhat limited domains
right you've all seen things like Dali
and gpd3 which are fun right but they
aren't having that much effect on kind
of the important issues and I think
there's this breadth of computational
tools that can help us ask questions
like okay what would actually happen if
we defunding the police to help us guide
these conversations in terms of like
I mean I'm also interested in just like
you know cool AI stuff don't get me
wrong I like you know I love this stuff
but
um in terms of like
risk I mean I think yeah all the risks
that you that you would think about are
real risk right
um you know if if you can build things
that can generally ask questions about
taking optimal actions they can use
those actions to cause harm and I think
thankfully there's like a lot of work
being done to think about these things
more deeply
um
but I think most of the solutions are
going to be societal right how do we
build the social structures that
encourage things used wisely as it is
for pretty much every other technology
that exists at the moment
um
well the short answer is it doesn't
really matter we try to bank
um
we did it with a bunch we did it with a
convolutional network
um
a dense Network dense Network and so on
so it doesn't actually matter that much
yeah so I one of the ways that as you
know forget Universal reasoning for the
moment if you just think about modern
machine learning methods that are
deployed in the world
in the current world
um they are often they often don't they
often trained in a way which doesn't
take into account their impact in the
world right and so that's fine if you're
just running this thing on your local
machine but you know if Google puts out
some new some new search engine that's
going to affect
how people behave right and so
um
the show answer is that
I need like a an agent should take into
account the implications of it being
deployed like it should take into
account like if this thing if the system
is actually operating in the world at
some scale the world is going to change
um and that that while changing may
actually be in terms of changes to
itself right or or changes to kind of
the people interacting with it and so
like mathematically you can
you know in some sense you can handle
this at least consensually in reality is
obviously a lot harder right how can an
agent reason about some you know smarter
better version of itself
[Music]
yeah it's a hard question
yeah so this is not my domain of
expertise you'd have to talk to my
co-founder but I can tell you one
project we're working on and that's like
large-scale genomic modeling
um so modeling basically
ancient population
um changes through history or the way
you know going and how did humans spread
out from from Africa
um using this kind of massive data set
of uh ancient genetic data that's been
collected
uh to make predictions about what
actually was kind of the state of the
world and kind of
ancient times
um and so you know it's like a massive
probabilistic model where we're
conditioning on all this data which
people have literally gone out and
collected
um many of which is thousands of years
old and it it's
presents like a tremendous inference
challenge
um but as I said like
the biological side is uh my co-founder
side and so if you're interested in that
kind of stuff then
I I can put you in touch
yeah
um
so yeah so we use programming languages
to express our knowledge and to express
the questions
um so like I said we have these
probabilistic programming languages that
allow you to express uncertainty allow
you to ask questions which are about
probability right so How likely is some
future event to occur like what is the
plausible values of these these unknown
variables then you have kind of counter
factual features which can be uh you
know included as I said that allow you
to ask these what-if questions
conditional evidence and then you can
think about what is the progression of
that right and so I could imagine a few
different ways that might
evolve right so one way that might
evolve is to say well actually there's
some finite set of things that we might
care about so we've you know figured out
uncertainty we've figured out causality
for the most part and maybe there's like
three or four other things and when we
get them we're done
or it might be that actually
the foundation is more like natural
language where
kind of in some sense the space the
things that you can talk about is
unbounded
and so one of the cool things about
things like gpt3 and so on for me it
isn't so much that they
um
are smart per se but it's more that they
allow you to ask questions in such a
flexible way so somewhat individually
I've transitioned from thinking okay
we've got this core
mathematical core and natural language
is just kind of like a noisy
approximation of it to think of that
maybe it's the other way around like
maybe something like natural language
should be the core
um
and but I don't know how that actually
works is a little bit trick like you
know you want you want the kind of
things that a mathematical language
gives you like you want consistency you
want coherency
um but you I think you also want the
kind of flexibility that natural
language gives you and I don't think we
know yet how to to tie those two
things together
if you do let me know
[Music]
um
cool are we any more questions
do we have time
[Applause]